I promise to love you every part of you
forever my girlfriend is uh 6 months
pregnant oh
congratulations do you know what you're
having my stepmom's a
werewolf my name's Detective Kate cross
well we've had a new piece of
information for a homicide investigation
did you see these
gentlemen
why are you
asking daddy alert who's the hot guy
hello you're not from here Anton us said
teach me in college did he help it in
any other way what do you mean I mean
like did he help you with his penis oh
my God
Gary why are you here I'm here for you
you need to stay away from me cuz I'm
going to protect my
pack pleas
maybe the universe is trying to tell us
that this is too
dangerous I love you and that is the
only one that
[Music]
matters the universe can go and eat a
bag of dicks that's the most romantic
thing anyone's ever said to
me